[music playing]
NARRATOR: Throughout
the world, there
are ancient traditions that
identify the center of the head
as being synonymous with
the center of the earth,
the center of the universe,
and the very center
of creation itself.
This center is often
depicted as egg-shaped
and is identified in some
cultures as the third eye.
There are multiple
cultures that point
us in this same direction.
The Hindus have it is as
the third eye or the bindi.
The Buddhists have the third
eye on Buddha's forehead.
We see symbology in
Mesoamerica, which
seems to symbolize its ability
to contact and communicate
with the higher
spiritual realms using
this secret symbol that is
consistent throughout all
the major world religions.
When you talk about the third
eye, it's about enlightenment.
It's about this connection
to the great unknown
or the force of the universe.
And we think that we are
separated from the world, when
in reality we are all connected
to every single object
in the universe.
And that inherently means
that we are directly connected
to every extraterrestrial being
throughout the entire universe.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: Is it possible that
the cosmic egg isn't only
a symbol for the universe or
how the universe was formed,
but represents a connection
that exists within each
and every human to the
cosmos, and possibly
to extraterrestrial
beings that came
to Earth in the distant past?
Ancient astronaut theorists
point out that while the third
eye has historically been
considered a metaphor,
there is an egg-shaped
structure within
the brain that is
critical in defining
what it means to be human--
the thalamus.
Shaped like two identical
eggs, the thalamus
lies at the center of
the brain and is the hub
responsible for relaying
information from most
of the sensory receptors.
Scientists studying the
effects of thalamic stimulation
on comatose patients
have recently
suggested the thalamus
might be the most important
factor in human consciousness.
HEATHER BERLIN: The thalamus
is like a relay station
in the brain.
So you have all the primary
sensory information coming in,
like information coming in
your eyes through your retina
and through your ears.
And all these sensations,
the first place
they go after the
primary sense organs,
is they get funneled
to the thalamus.
And then the thalamus
sorts out this information
and relays it to
the various ports
in the cortex that process that
primary sensory information.
If the thalamus is
damaged, usually it
will knock out consciousness.
It's a very critical point where
all the information comes to,
and then it's distributed
in the cortex.
WILLIAM HENRY: The thalamus is
called the lamp, the open eye,
even the third eye.
And when you look at this,
you wonder, was it in fact
a gift from extraterrestrial
beings that awakened us?
That enabled us to become
connected to the divine
or extraterrestrial realm?
Perhaps the
extraterrestrials that
had a hand in fashioning
the human body
and tweaking the human brain
placed the thalamus there,
in its egg shape,
as a connecting link
to the greater civilization out
of which we originally emerged.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: Could the thalamus
be the physical representation
of what ancient cultures
referred to as the third eye?
And if so, might this brain
structure act as a connection
to greater forces
in the universe?
As incredible as
this notion may seem,
ancient astronaut theorists
suggest that the thalamus can
also be found represented
in one of the most prominent
symbols of ancient Egypt--
the Eye Of Horus.
DAVID CHILDRESS:
The Eye of Horus,
also known as the Eye of Ra,
was a symbol of protection,
royal power, and good health.
But it was also known as
the Eye of Providence,
the all-seeing eye of God.
Now, what is incredible is
if you look at the thalamus
and all of the structures
surrounding that,
it looks like the Eye of Horus.
The similarity is really
pretty astonishing.